so first question uh we have from sean
walsh uh and that is will the oncoming
autumn and winter favor ukrainian forces
as it did at the start of the war when
uh russian tanks were hampered by that
soft muddy ground
it plays both ways uh the rainy season
in ukraine is summer and autumn so
they're coming into that really wet
season now or partly in it and that
won't help russian armored vehicles
when it gets very cold armored vehicles
can use the hard ground but there's that
period in between when it's more
difficult weather never plays it all one
way generally speaking cold winters or
difficult winters play better for the
defenders than the attackers if you're
trying to attack you've got to move
around you've got to keep moving you've
got to keep things agile whereas if
you're defending you just got to stay
where you are so uh cold winters
difficult winters are miserable for
everybody but they're more miserable for
the attackers than the defenders are are
the russians now the defenders they are
um in the they're not moving uh in the
donbass they look as if they're digging
in in the donbass for the winter and
they are now defending in kursan in the
south and the ukrainians are attacking
so the ukrainians will want to get their
attack over they want to they want a
success before the rain gets too wet
before the ground gets wet and before
the cold weather starts in november
december and for that reason they're on
a bit of a timetable now they've got to
prove to the west and themselves that
they can attack successfully more than
village by village a wide area attack to
put the russians on the back foot and is
it fair to say that the last month has
been a little bit of a stalemate and has
the weather got anything to do with that
sort of too favorable the weather almost
yeah i wouldn't say
people say stalemate i mean not many
arrows on the map have appeared but
there's quite a lot going on and so yeah
the weather's got something to do with
it i think the the russians have decided
that they can't mount any more big
offensives before the winter which means
in the spring and they now look as if
they're they're taking a breath for
probably a big offensive in the spring
the ukrainians are using this window in
the weather before it starts to get cold
and very difficult i think to gain what
they can in the southwest jackie asks as
it's six months since russia invaded and
clearly not going putin's way so far how
likely is it that uh he could resort to
a nuclear attack yeah i mean this always
comes up and it's it's a fair question
um the point is that a nuclear attack
even a tactical nuclear weapon which you
know would cover so two or three
kilometers with real destruction can
only be used against concentrated troops
and the ukrainians are not concentrated
they they are they're fairly dispersed
it's only troop uh concentrations that
offer a valuable target even for very
small nuclear weapons and of course
bigger nuclear weapons to use a new uh
against you know a city like sumi or
chernihiv as a as a punishment to the
ukrainians would put putin so completely
on the wrong side of history that even
the chinese i think would would drop him
if that were the case so i think we are
a long way from the use of nuclear
weapons but i have i mean just today a
former british ambassador has said
um on twitter he said look if all else
fails for russia and if putin is faced
with a really awful defeat you cannot
rule it out and i take his his line
seriously and are there any other
weapons that they have in their arsenal
that are somewhere in between what
they've used so far and the the sort of
targeted nuclear weapon that they could
still bring out yes i mean hypersonic
weapons the moabs they're called the the
uh uh um the emergency called the mother
of all bombs a massive ordnance ordnance
air burst so they've got big weapons
that do as much damage as a small
nuclear weapon and we've seen some of
those these sort of earthquake bombs
they could be used and those are
thermobaric bombs which create massive
overpressure they're very very
destructive again they can only usefully
be used against concentration of forces
we may see that we may see it um but not
this year we might see it if the
russians government come under real
pressure to losing real territory that
matters to them maybe after christmas uh
in terms of uh other questions elizabeth
asks are there any truth to the rumors
about putin's health that was a big
rumor a few months ago it's kind of gone
away yes
he's said to have pancreatic cancer and
all sorts of things he moves around with
doctors he he doesn't spend very long
without going to consult his doctors but
personally i think he's just a
hypochondriac um
and he's been rumored for many years to
hit the botox very hard indeed so my my
theory is always that he'll die of botox
uh but there's no real evidence that
this man is ill and even if he were and
people think well he is on a timetable
to do something before he dies i don't
think it's like that he's on a timetable
before this whole thing falls apart on
him and for that he's maybe got a year
or 18 months before this war that he
cannot win at the moment
actually turns uh in on itself within
the kremlin so he's on a timetable
anyway health or no um ahmed asks uh if
you see belarus joining the war at any
point no no lukashenko the president
belarus has been very clear very careful
he's allowed belarus territory to be
used but he's he himself is under real
pressure domestically i mean the war is
not popular in belarus and he's got a
lot of opposition against him which
nearly deposed him just over a year ago
and he's he's kept out of it as have
many of the uh russia's allies i mean
that you look at the um the um
central treaty security organization
which includes kazakhstan and armenia
and tajikistan none of them none of them
have actually helped the russians out
and in kazakhstan's case president
takirov of kazakhstan i mean putin saved
his bacon last year when there were
internal um uh riots and putin sent in
the paratroopers that suppressed them so
taka revosed him but even they have not
actually joined in i think putin must be
spitting blood and feathers about the
failure of his allies to actually send
troops so lukashenko no
he might join in if the russians were
clearly winning in the final stages of
the war he might then rush into it in
order to show how much solidarity he
feels but his position is so delicate
himself he won't take he won't step over
the border at the moment it's such an
interesting question we're going to come
to china later on in the hour but but
outside of china what about the other
allies mighty have expected a little
maybe not an ally but what about turkey
could they have been more neutral than
they've been well be less supportive of
the west position turkey's playing it
both ways because they're sending baira
to drones to ukraine which are having a
big effect on the war at the same time
they're helping putin diplomatically
because they won't implement sanctions
uh western sanctions and so erdogan of
turkey is really trying to play uh both
sides to the middle and whether he can
keep on doing that is a question the um
other russian backers are the basket
cases so he's got backing from syria
he's got backing from some african
leaders where the russians are involved
he's got a little bit of backing in
north africa from haftar in a breakaway
group in libya who's sitting in benghazi
i mean basically they've they've got the
some of the dregs of the middle east and
africa in terms of mercenary forces who
are being paid quite handsomely by
handsomely by the russians to join the
wagner group and go to ukraine they are
vicious they are
not without use but they can't fit into
a general combined arms effort so you
know they can massacre people and they
can take ground that's already been
pounded by artillery but they're not a
whole lot of use otherwise let's uh
switch focus and talk about one of
ukraine's biggest allies and supporters
and that is boris johnson how
significant was it that he made that
that trip there it's a question uh from
from jack yeah it was interesting i mean
it took me by surprise certainly that he
suddenly turned up and i saw melinda
simmons right by his side in that first
clip that we saw who was the british
ambassador very good british ambassador
in kiev and i thought well good for you
because this must be a nightmare getting
a prime minister into kiev on the day
when the missiles might have been
raining down that must have been a
security
problem of high importance but they they
did it and it was a it was a sort of
diplomatic coup which will probably
annoy a lot of other european leaders
but the message he was taking was that
you know we are prepared to take you
know some degree of personal risk to
come and support you and i'm sure the
message was that whatever happens in
terms of you know whichever leader
becomes uh
prime minister whichever the tory
leaders becomes prime minister in a
couple of weeks time they will be no
less committed than i am i'm sure that
was the message today
and in terms of of
the continuity aspect of this is it
important that the mod is still led by
the same person in ben wallace as it
appears might be the case whoever wins
or or does that not really make a
difference as long as the general gist
from the top is is still well yeah i
think that just from the top will be
consistent i mean i think i think ben
wallace probably
my guess is he will remain minister of
defense i think he wants to the whole of
that mod team you know they knew when
everyone else was leaving the government
the mod team just kept their heads down
and carried on doing their job when the
government was collapsing everywhere
they didn't and i think they take some
pride in that because they think look
we've got a more important job to do
than worry too much about domestic
politics and the mod is absolutely
committed to training i mean that
there's this sort of quarterly every 100
or 120 days they're getting more people
through and so they are committed to
that they're committed to winning
ukrainian training ukrainian forces yeah
the issue is how much more can we give
um that they need um because we've run
down most of our own stocks and this
ukrainian war is teaching us uh if we if
if we needed to be taught that we could
lose most of the british army in an
afternoon
if we were fighting at this level of
intensity simply because of the lack of
backup and sustainability we're on very
very thin margins and so you know we've
given so much of our anti-tank stuff
away
we can't give too many of our vehicles
away because we've barely got enough for
ourselves we have got to gear up like a
lot of western countries to rearm a bit
in order to give material to ukraine and
make ourselves a bit safer and that
message is out there loud and clear but
no politician has yet picked it up it's
amazing to hear you you framed the scale
of that in fact alan also asked will the
mod be ramping up military recruitment
in the face of an aggressive russian
state which i guess is in terms of
personnel um but but we need to
replenish our supplies in general we do
and the the numbers um are at a historic
low i mean the army was 82 000
it's b it's due to go down to 72 500 in
the integrated review which is a is
whatever whatever is the right number
for the army it's not 72 500 that it can
either be lower than that or a good deal
higher than that depending on what you
what what you want the army to do and
the army itself has made it very clear
and ben wallace has made it clear that
the the forces are too small
that they needs to be expanded but he's
getting no traction at the moment not
much from downing street even with boris
in charge and he's not getting any
attraction yet with les trusts or rishi
sunak and we'll see whoever becomes
prime minister how that goes but nobody
in the defense business i mean the
analytical community that i'm a part of
none of us think that british defense at
the moment is adequate to the not only
to the task that sets itself but to the
tasks it will be called upon in the next
five years partly because of the ukraine
war wow uh a sobering thought michael
thank you so much for that that's just
the the first uh segment of our special
hour q a we're just getting started here
we'll be back after the break and
specifically talking uh about current
ongoing situations like the nuclear
power plant like crimea don't go
anywhere we'll be back on sky news
tonight in a couple minutes
[Music]
[Music]
i'm becky johnson a sky news
correspondent part of the team based
here in the midland
allegations of exploitation in
leicester's clothing factories aren't
new in fact it's been an open secret in
this city for years
[Music]
made for people who want clarity in an
uncertain world
we're getting more and more stabbings
and essentially i think it's more and
more younger children as a team we're
not really surprised by anything these
days
so it's reports of a male who's been
stabbed repeatedly in the leg
here in the diverse industrial heart of
england we hear from people who have
real stories to tell
parents are going to complain like this
and schools better get ready for it
these protests are being organized
primarily by people who aren't parents
at the school
so some patients aren't going to survive
this we have to be prepared that
patients will die from from this illness
staff here are currently identifying
wards that could be turned into areas
where patients with kobit 19 could be
isolated
[Music]
the river 7 is still rising and people
here in ironbridge have been told it
could go up by another meter before it
starts to go back down
it's going to be a long slow process to
put it back together again
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
i'm ivan bonillo i'm a sailor
i spent half time of my life on the on
the sea
we have a factory we can convert this
plastic to energy and so after at the
end we can minimize the footprint carbon
of the board
welcome back this is a special sky news
tonight q a on six months of war in
ukraine with us still is our defense
analyst michael clark who's answering
your questions uh in this uh segment of
the show we're going to focusing on some
more local uh ongoing uh situations and
let's start with this power plant in
zapparita the nuclear power plant
realistically what is the solution here
that is possible that people might agree
to yeah i mean the the solution would be
to have an iaea team international
atomic energy authority team or a un
team
um go into the plant and look after it
maybe with ukrainian workers who are
used to it and that all the military say
withdrawals to five kilometers all the
way around it but there's no question
that the russians have been using the
plan to store munitions and to use it as
a base i've got direct evidence of that
i've seen it myself i haven't seen
direct evidence that they're firing out
of the plant they're using they've got
artillery firing from the planet they're
accused of it i haven't actually seen
that evidence but the russians are
certainly using the plant as a kind of
safe haven so
the the answer would be for them to
agree and the ukrainians agree which i'm
sure they would to a sort of a five five
kilometer exclusion zone and let the
international community be responsible
for keeping the plan going that would be
the answer
but like the grain shipments it might be
a long process of negotiation with the
russians my follow-up on on that i have
to say michael is i mean ideal if we
could get there but can we really blame
the russians who are at war yeah for
storing weapons there's rather a clever
ploy because if ukraine attacks it's
it's well it's unlikely that ukraine
attacks because of it yes
it is i mean warfare people will tend to
do that but i mean the solution is to
exclude this area from from the war
because it's an international problem
and the problem is not the reactors
incidentally i mean you know they're
they're the reactors they're all encased
in concrete they will withstand bombs
they'll stand rockets they'll withstand
an aircraft crashing into them they're
designed for that the issue is the
turbine hall the issue is the coolant
system and that's far less secure in all
nuclear plants and so if the coolant is
actually turned off or or interfered
with then the reactors will go critical
that's what happened at fukushima that's
what happened in a different way at um
earlier in chernobyl um so it's it's the
main problem is not the reactors it's
the way the reactors are maintained
that's the the problem realistically
russia unlikely to agree to anything
like that no yeah i don't think they
will i mean i think they'll just keep
playing this issue along and saying that
they're not using it for any nefarious
purposes they're doing their best to
keep it going and ukrainian should stop
attacking it um let's move on to to cry
crimea and how important condor asks
this uh how important is crimea to both
the russians and the ukrainians
um very um i mean it's very important to
the russians
because crimea is regarded was regarded
as an intrinsic part of the soviet union
it was only given to ukraine in 1954 by
khrushchev uh it was given to the
ukrainian soviet socialist republic to
administer in 1954 and the russians in
the 19th century when they took it over
by conquest had basically got rid of all
the tartars they they ethnically
cleansed ukraine of the tartars the
cossacks who were based there who
for whom it was their homeland and so it
is effectively because it's been
colonized over more than centuries more
or less 100 percent or 90 odd percent
russian with some tartar minorities who
don't do very well
and importantly of course there's
sevastopol um and the base at sevastopol
is an incredibly important naval base
for russian partly because it shows that
russia's got the ability to project
power that is the base from which the
black sea fleet operates it they project
power not in the not only the black sea
but throughout the mediterranean so it
matters to the russians if they were to
lose crimea which which legally they
should because it's ukrainian territory
and was recognized as ukrainian in 1991
and 1992 30 odd years ago when ukraine
became an independent state but if they
did lose it they would regard that as
intrinsically losing a piece of russia
they'd be wrong to think that but it's
what they would think does ukraine have
the capability to take it back no i mean
not for some time um the ukrainians they
claim that they will and they have to
say that of course they do um but they
will fight i mean if they if there is a
negotiated end to this crisis sometimes
say next year or late next year whatever
the great bargaining chip the ukrainians
will have will be to say look we will we
will have back all the territory you
took from us plus the donbass which is
always ukrainian but we'll leave the
status of crimea as it is i mean they're
not going to offer that now but when the
if they are in a more dominant position
in negotiations if they ever get to that
point then that would be the big offer
but they can't say that now they have to
say that crimea is ukrainian which
legally it is and that they will fight
for it but their chances of of invading
it successfully in taking it is very
very low despite that rich asks why
ukraine taking so long to blow up the
crimean bridge that was built by russia
oh the cursed straight yeah yeah yes but
this is the this is the strait between
russia proper proper you know russia
itself and that little tip of crimea
right to the east of crimea and it used
to be a ferry there um until 2014 that's
all it was just a ferry and the russians
built this enormous bridge
and it is the the kirsch bridge now and
that is the only
reliable land link between russia and
crimea that doesn't run through
ukrainian territory further north
um
the
ukrainians would i think
they're not sure they want to target it
actually because it would be a targeted
it would be targeting something that
leads into russia and i think the
russians would take that very badly but
also the russians are defending it
ferociously they've got lots of air
defense there and they've got they've
got there this enormous ship which they
claim is a cruise ship which just
happens to sit there and this cruise
ship has got about eight enormous dishes
on the top enormous radar dishes and
this is a reflective radar ship which is
there to actually um confuse any
incoming missiles and this ship has been
sitting there for weeks and the russians
can say it's a cruise ship well they
must have some fabulous tv on that
cruise ship because it's nothing but but
radar dishes on the top well they've
probably got sky they must have sky tv
they're tuning in to us right now um or
perhaps go atlantic watching game of
thrones but uh either way let's let's
move on to what's the likelihood that
that russia
will
if they take odessa well a take odessa
and b move on to moldova potentially uh
after that that's a question from yeah
they can't do that um for a long time to
come they've tried that's what they
wanted to do but i mean they didn't take
nikolaev and they've been pushed back
from nickelodeon mikolaim is 85
miles away from odessa and odessa's 30
miles away from the moldovan border so
they're more than 100 miles away from
the border with moldova and they're
going backwards in that region not
forwards um odessa is it can still be
bombed it can still be attacked but
remember odessa and ports around it like
uh um uh chernar mosque are being used
for this grain deal which is now taking
place so
the russians don't want to bomb odessa
although they have done and they claim
they might and china most places like
that
for now they're pretty safe because the
russian troops can't get there their
maritime forces in the black sea that
looks as if they're ready to invade
can't because they've lost too many of
those forces they're just too far away
and the grain deals gives odessa some
degree of international russia is sort
of honoring that grain deal
to a degree they're getting about a
million tons a month out but they should
be getting five million tons a month out
so ships are leaving but not in the
numbers that they need they need about
400 450 trips to get the 20 odd million
tons out that is backed up there and
they've only had a couple of dozen so
far um so i mean i'm expecting the
russians to start to interfere with that
to start to play games with it but so
far they haven't but the extent has been
small so far quick question from alice
on events of this past week could the
killing of dario dugina be linked to a
russian resistance and then conveniently
blamed on ukraine afterwards yeah i mean
i'm pretty certain that the ukrainians
had nothing to do with this i mean
there's no advantage to them there's
everything to lose by this sort of an
assassination in moscow and why would
they try and assassinate you know
somebody who was a nobody to be honest i
mean just had crazy views and she was
the daughter of alexander dugan who also
has crazy views but had no influence
despite what people say with putin he
had had influence but he's never met
putin never been in government um so
he's never met putin no no i mean he was
he was a bit influential in 19 2014 and
his work that he wrote on civilizations
about the russian sort of mission for
the world was circulated around
government you know the way the
americans do they want to find a text
and tell everybody to read it so he had
a guru status but he's basically a
self-publicist
and that so i really don't believe we
don't know but i really don't believe
that ukraine has had much anything to do
with that um the um ilya pomerenkov uh
who said i think yeah day before
yesterday he said oh it's the um
national republican army nobody ever
heard of them before but this nra he
said are responsible for bombing some of
the recruitment officers in russia and
they're they're responsible for some
violent um acts in russia against the
war well maybe maybe but it's just as
likely to have been a sort of a mafia
hit or something like that or it might
be a false flag attack uh in the sense
that this is because if i mean last
night i was looking at some of the
translated versions on rossia one the uh
the russian mainline news channel and
they were saying i mean all these
characters stand around every night and
they said all this has been created by
ukraine estonia and britain and they but
they they blame britain in particular
and they say it's british intelligence
is behind this and british intelligence
is trying to destabilize europe and
bellingcat the the investigative
journalists they're behind it as well
and the daily mail they mentioned the
daily mail they said all these things
are written in the daily mail they pay
us the compliment
but in a strange way of believing that
we're behind everything um and so
there's a real sort of anti-britishness
every night more or less did i have a
look at it uh on racial one and uh ntv
tv some of their main line channels
which are all state-sponsored channels
they're all mouthpieces of the kremlin
um but i mean the the duggan issue i
think will run and it may well be that
it's certainly being whipped up in
russia as justification for mobilization
and that mobilization is against ukraine
but against ukraine's backers
particularly the british
very interesting as always uh michael
thank you for that segment much more so
to come on the special q a next segment
we'll be talking about how this war
might possibly end and where it goes
next
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back uh to this special sky news
tonight q a on six months of the war in
ukraine with uh us uh is of course
defense analyst michael clark who's
answering your questions on to a topic
uh that we've called end of war
possibilities so you've got to get your
predictive hat on here michael so so
first question from neil um without
western aid would the ukrainians be able
to hold up russian advances no simple as
that i mean they've got the manpower
because ukraine say that they're they're
training 700 000 people with a million
in mind and i think that's plausible
because it's a country of 44 million
people and they're fighting for their
lives so they've certainly got the
manpower and they've got they've got the
moral component and they're desperate
and they will train and they'll do
whatever needs to be done they'll be
very brave but in terms of equipment
they they don't have enough of
everything that they need and they don't
have the offensive equipment which they
can only get from us or from the west
for these long-range strikes for
accurate artillery for missiles and for
the intelligence counter-battery radars
all sort of things that make these
weapons effective they depend on us if
if the west tomorrow withdrew all of its
support then ukraine would be wrapped up
militarily within a couple of months i
would guess well and and how much more
is coming that they haven't had yet and
with three billion dollars announced
from the us but but in terms of the
training and expertise they've needed to
maximize this western aid are they now
up to speed on that or could they get a
lot better in the coming months well
that's a good question um one thing that
they're not getting enough tanks and
they're not getting enough armored
personnel carriers the armored vehicles
that they need for offensive operations
they're getting lots of of um handheld
weapons anti-tank weapons light weapons
weapons for defense but to go on the
offensive which they're trying to do in
cursion they need the heavy metal and
they've had a fair bit of that but not
enough and they certainly don't have
enough air power because to go on the
offensive you've got to integrate ground
and air power in a very effective brutal
way they're not getting enough of that
either
with day 181 now i mean when you and i
were talking on days 20 and back then
one of the things we were saying was if
the west gave anything other than
defensive weapons then russia wouldn't
would think that was a nato involvement
in the war and could uh
put strikes on europe i mean is that how
russia is still thinking or are we now
sneaking in with defensive weapons we've
crossed a series of thresholds as the as
the war has gone on as russia's behavior
has has become exposed i mean this
brutality the war crimes and so on that
that has actually strengthened the
consensus in the west and one by one
these thresholds have been crossed so
yes we'll give them long-range artillery
yes we'll give them multiple launch
rocket systems we won't yet give them
the aircraft that they would really like
the f-16 but who knows um i mean but
they've had you know mig-29s from the
stocks in eastern europe and so on
one by one western
thresholds are being crossed by us as we
see the need that ukrainians have to
actually fight this war efficiently and
there's no there's no getting away from
it the ukrainian you know we are
fighting a war against russia
via ukraine
and it's it's it's now become
an industrial war a war in the
industrial age and it will be one or the
side that will prevail is the side that
can mobilize resources most efficiently
and apply them and if we don't mobilize
the resources for ukraine then we will
not prevail if russia doesn't mobilize
its resources it will not prevail let's
take the f-16 then as an example what's
stopping that being given to them at the
moment is it a collective fear from the
west of how russia would respond or is
it individual nations are the uk and the
u.s already ready to give that or what
yeah it's an american fear that that
would be maybe a step too far but we'll
see we'll see um
you know i mean a completely new
aircraft f-16s are very good everybody
would like them um turkey wants them
they want the newest version so on but
pilots have got to be trained so you
can't just give them 30 or 40 f-16s and
hope that they will make a difference so
it would take some time and the russians
would certainly if they saw nato
aircraft flying over ukraine attacking
their forces they would then think that
they had some justification for saying
look we are being attacked by nato just
because they're
ukrainian pilots in the cockpit doesn't
mean to say we're not being attacked by
nato so that would be a big threshold
but i wouldn't rule it out because at
some point we've got to decide how much
are we prepared to back ukraine next
year after christmas
um to prevail in this war we talk about
winning the war we mean prevailing to
throw back this crazy imperialist
adventure that putin has launched that's
what winning will mean not not winning
the war by you know wrecking russia
that's not not on the cards winning the
war by prevailing and throwing back
certainly the gains that have been made
since the 24th of february let's uh
touch on that russian side then so how
long can can russia sustain the war
considering how many resources they have
left that's a question from rob it's
patchy i mean the thing they've got most
of is artillery they've got artillery
tubes and they've got artillery shells
it's estimated they've got about 20
million shells in store some going back
many many years so whether they still
work or not we don't know they can
manufacture about a million and a half a
year because they're not hard to
manufacture
but even on on present usage rates if
they keep on fighting the way they are
now using these you know thousands of
shells at a time they're using as many
shells now as the wehrmacht used
in the 1943-44
in russia i mean this got sec it's
become second world war proportions in
terms of artillery
if those usage rates they can probably
only carry on for two years and that's
with artillery if we look at tanks and
armored personnel carriers then it's
less than that because they just don't
have the the stocks that are still
usable
and most important of all the russians
don't have the manpower at the moment so
all this means that if the russians
carry on as they are now they can they
can fight into next year and maybe the
year afterwards but they will do worse
and worse if they do that until unless
or until they mobilize efficiently at
the moment they're going through a sort
of crypto mobilization they're not
saying they're mobilizing but they're
trying to mobilize in all sorts of ways
it's not really working at some point
and that's why the um
these false flag attacks may be
important of the assassinations of
dugina and so on is that if they go for
full mobilization then
then everything changes and then they
will gear up uh their industry they'll
move their civilian industry into war
production and then they could go on for
many many years um ricky asks what are
the chances of putin being ousted
domestically
um
we don't know i mean i think personally
i think putin is finished because he's
in a complete blind alley this is a
stupid war and there's no way out of it
for him other than some sort of
humiliation and defeat um i really don't
believe there's a sensible way out um
but
popular opinion is not going to oust him
because russia is more repressive now or
as repressive as it was during stalin's
uh later days um
and that repressive now yeah it really
is um i mean the uh
the the the
ex-editor talking about to say that the
invasion is a war is is it looks as if
it will get somebody five years in
prison there are three and a half
thousand cases of people who are being
accused of disrespecting the military
and that carries a prison term of five
years
um and journalists now if they don't
leave russia they simply can't say the
word war five years in prison if you do
it's very very repressive so
there's no easy way for
um the public who are getting
disenchanted with this for all sorts of
indications of that that they can't
really express it if putin is removed
it'll be by the elite around him it'll
be because the oligarchs turn on him
because they they see that russia's in
such a blind alley and it really begins
to affect them and so it could happen
quickly or it could happen in two or
three years time the longer it it is
before it happens the more russia will
be
either on its knees or severely
disadvantaged by the economic mess that
it's getting itself into and if he was
removed any which way who takes over
could it be a worse outcome yes it won't
be a nice person um i mean it will be a
man he won't be a woman um and petruchev
is often thought to be a successor who's
more extreme at least in his views than
putin whether he's as competent or not
we don't know but true services national
security adviser um it could be um
kirienko who's his deputy chief of staff
who's also a tough guy
could be lavrov who's gone over to the
foreign minister who's gone over to the
dark side in recent years and he's a
very strange man now
or um shogu the defense minister who
everyone thought was on a death store a
few months ago doesn't seem to be he too
has a putin view it won't be somebody
like medvedev or volodin these people
are are not they're they're on they're
not on the way up but uh petruchev and
karienko lavrov shogu they're all on the
way up within the putin circle so if
there were a coup
then my at the moment you'd say well
probably one of those four unless
somebody emerges from the woodwork that
we're not really aware of at the moment
um in terms of
the west's involvement what are the
chances at this stage kind of going back
to the earlier part of this section of
the conversation of full western
engagement in a really terrifying way in
a world war iii type way
yeah i don't worry too much about the
world war three uh ideas um i mean
there's lots of books written over the
last 30 years about world war three and
they're all full of there's a chapter in
the middle east chapter in africa
chapter one russian chapter on uh the
taiwan straits and they're all plausible
but the thing that they lack is what
would unite them into a world war i mean
you know the first world war was the
seven years war um
1756-63
and that was united by the empires of
britain and france the first world war
20th century was united again by the
empires of germany on the one hand in
austria hungary russia and britain and
france on the other the second world war
was united by ideology it united a
series of disparate conflicts that all
seem to become world war
that's not the case now we can think of
lots of conflicts
over china and taiwan in the middle east
in central asia in russia
in other parts in africa east africa
west africa there's nothing that unites
them and there's no countries that unite
them all and so the idea that this could
could as it were escalate to world war
three i just is not plausible to me but
could it become more serious yes it
could um could it become more
geographically dispersed yes it could
and it could become a war between nato
and russia we i mean we're all trying to
avoid that and that is a red line which
both sides have
honoured at the moment the russians are
very careful not to cross that red line
and we've been very careful not to cross
it but you can't say it would never be
crossed but so that part in particular
which i think a lot of people here would
would
maybe you've got the better definitions
but start calling it a world war that
kind of feel like that uh if both sides
got more fully involved i mean of what
you've said in the last 10 minutes
one aspect might lead to that which is
russia going into full war footing yeah
i mean how likely is that yeah um
i don't know i'd say it's it's less than
50 50 because going on to a full war
footing would be very very serious and
i'm sure putin will try to do all he can
to avoid that in the next year but if he
ends up in a year's time with a
situation that's worse than it is now
for him then you know you can't rule
that out and yes what we're talking
about would be not world war three but a
general european war that's the way we
tend to think of it a general war in
europe and um i mean i never thought i
would live long enough to see that
prospect as a realistic prospect but now
i fear i'm going to live long enough to
see that
well we hope it doesn't develop in that
way but we hope you live long enough to
potentially uh just say
those sorts of possibilities that don't
quite materialize michael great stuff
we're going to take a quick break more
questions and answers with michael to
come just the other side of this break
[Music]
well this war has been going on for six
months already and and of course russia
is
is threatening more is is more
aggressive than ever
because they are clearly not winning
this war as they expected to be a very
short uh short
period of time when they achieve their
goals
what is important
here is that we keep on isolating russia
and we keep on pushing them so that they
would go back to its borders and and
withdraw the aggression we have to
support ukraine every way we can
so that they can win this war because if
aggression pays off uh somewhere it
serves as an invitation to use it
elsewhere
what has happened is that
when
russia attacked
georgia crimea
donbass then nothing happened
to them i mean they were not punished
for the aggression so
the message they got was that this pays
off because eventually they have more
territories and every time with every uh
next step they have been bolder if you
look at their um their way of of
operating then they have been attacking
civilian uh civilians
it is a war crime according to
international law uh when you target
civilians what we saw in mariupol was
complete
destruction of the whole city and
especially bombing hospitals bombing
places where there were marks that they
here are the children
but
so so
we shouldn't we shouldn't listen to what
they are saying it's an information
operation but we should look at what
they're doing and what we see happening
in ukraine is completely
vice versa we are very grateful for
britain to
be our framework country so we have had
very good cooperation
with great britain and and the troops
here present working together with our
own defense forces have been a very good
deterrent for for russia as well uh that
attacking us would also mean attacking
uk or france or the other countries who
are present here
therefore we are very grateful
welcome back as we continue our special
question and answer program on six
months of the war in ukraine our defense
analyst michael clark has been answering
your questions throughout this hour and
before we take more of those questions
uh do remember to scan the qr code on
the screen
and hear stories from those on europe's
new front line uh on sky news's ukraine
war diaries podcast so do scan that qr
code subscribe to it and some of our
other podcasters where all of them are
available
for free wherever you get your podcasts
from we'll leave that qr code on the
screen for you for just a little moment
longer michael back to the q a peter
jackson asks what are the red lines for
each side in a negotiated peace deal and
and is a negotiated peace deal likely
that's one of the problems we don't know
what the red lines are i mean both sides
make maximalist demands so the
ukrainians say we want to get all of our
territory back and they would say that
because they're fighting with their
lives the russians say that
they want to protect their people in the
donbass but also they want to protect
their people in the south and they're
going to annex parts of the south and
they've made it pretty clear that they
don't regard ukraine as a proper state
and it deserves to be brought into
russia so we don't really know what the
red lines are as i say the red line that
they've observed which we all observed
is that nato and russian forces shall
not come up against each other directly
now if that red line stays we'll see but
at the moment that's the thing that's
stabilizing it as far as it is
stabilized my guess is that the basis i
mean i think what peter's talking about
is that the basis for negotiation would
be if the russians
agree to leave the territories that
they've conquered since the 24th of
february
that would that would be the base of us
basis of a ceasefire even if the two
breakaway republics remained in being
and crimea remains where it is or as it
is and that that would be a that
wouldn't be a peace deal but it would be
a ceasefire and that might last for a
few years before it broke down so crimea
would remain fully russian luhansk and
and the donations would be sort of
pseudo
yeah i think they go back to a sort of
minsk three process minsk two was the
peace deal that france germany and
russia and ukraine put together it was a
lousy deal to be honest it was always a
deal for the the for the two breakaway
republics to get more and more
independent and more and more linked to
russia so
going back to that
might be the basis at least for a
ceasefire and a ceasefire might last for
two or three years before it broke down
i mean my view of this is this is a
generational struggle because russia and
russian leaders that as far as we can
see into the future believe that ukraine
has no right to exist so the ukrainians
are facing 50 60 70 years two or three
generations in which they will be
threatened by their neighbor that's 10
times bigger than they are now you can't
fight a war that lasts 60 or 70 years in
reality so it'll be an on off struggle
and that struggle has become an
existential struggle
about democracy in the west and
autocracy and dictatorship in the east
of europe and so that struggle will will
go in a series of i think
wars we're into the second war now the
first war was 2014 the second war is
2022. there might be a ceasefire in 2023
which lasts till you know 2027 2028 and
the third war will be thereafter that's
i think is what we're probably looking
at
and the the red lines the negotiating
process will change with each phase that
it goes through but we've got to be
clear about this we're looking at a
fundamental
uh problem of european security bigger
than anything we've faced since 1939
which will go on for a couple of
generations i'm gonna jump around here
for for the final six seven minutes to
make sure we get some of these questions
in so sanctions
why are they not hurting russia more are
they but it's just not as as well
reported because it feels to many
europeans like like is the other way
around yeah no i mean they're hurting us
as well because sanctions do that's the
point everybody suffers in a way but the
russian economy is underlying economy is
not doing it all well um they are a
cash-rich economy because of energy
because of gas and oil prices that's all
they've got and if you look at other
things i mean certain little indicators
so you know western films blockbuster
movies are not available in russia now
the cinemas can't show them they don't
have them and so just russian films are
being shown um shop fronts are empty or
they're being replaced now by russian
shop fronts which haven't got very much
stuff um the russian economy the
underlying economy is in pretty poor
shape but they've got plenty of cash
because of energy so and that's the
that's the safety valve for putin and
the russian elite but undoubtedly
sanctions they're never going to stop
this war but sanctions punish russia to
the point where in one year two years
three years they realize that unless
there is some sort of ceasefire and some
lifting of sanctions their economy will
just keep on going into a blind alley
could china help russia win this war and
if the west annoyed them enough on
taiwan would that be a trigger they
could yeah they could help i mean
china's putin's only hope actually of
getting off the hook but the chinese are
being very careful they're they are
supporting putin xi jinping himself he's
very close to putin as a person but xi
jinping is not a very flexible man and
he's under quite a lot of pressure
himself um
the chinese i think could uh they're not
breaking sanctions by and large they're
giving some help but nothing really
dramatic and they're very worried the
chinese about secondary sanctions which
americans could put on them of secondary
sanctions that is if you deal with a
company that deals with russia then you
can be subject to secondary sanctions
and remember the world is going into a
global recession and china's suffering
more than more from that than most other
countries we think we're in the state
just look at china they are going into a
fairly deep recession and they've got
this crazy zero covert policy which xi
jinping runs which is making everything
worse so the chinese are now very
careful not to trip over sanctions
policy by helping the russians out too
much two more questions hopefully we
squeeze them this one's from crazy but
it's a it's a great question despite uh
despite the name western intelligence we
get these updates on twitter uh from
from
uh the mod i mean does that mean there's
even more intelligence that they're not
sharing oh for sure how do they decide
what to release publicly has already
been shared for a month earlier that
when people talk about sharing
intelligence what you're getting is a
conclusion no intelligence organization
shares real raw intelligence and they
certainly don't ever share their sources
even with each other i mean the number
one rule of intelligence is protect your
sources and that means you protect
british sources from the americans
american sources are protected from the
british we don't share our sources but
when you've actually put the raw
intelligence together and you have a
conclusion then you may choose for
political reasons to share that
conclusion by and large it's better not
to do that but in certain situations it
can be beneficial but believe me
intelligence isn't being shared
the headlines are being shared and you
know the headline is like the tip of an
iceberg there's an awful lot of stuff
underneath which is very very closely
guarded and very quickly said earlier
that our overall forces are a bit
depleted and we need to fix that what
about our intelligence services oh
they're the best still or not yeah
they're they're one of the jewels in our
crown as far as security goes with with
the americans we have the best
intelligence feeds in the world bar none
and british intelligence is still the
one area of british security policy that
everybody takes seriously everybody
wants to be a part of it and the five
eyes club this america canada britain
australia new zealand the five the old
anglo-saxon powers who share
intelligence products everybody wants to
be in the five eyes everybody wants to
join it but nobody else can um final
question you've got about 90 seconds to
sum this up for who's winning six months
in
neither side is winning
but neither side is losing either and
that's a fairly delphic idea but
um if the ukrainians can see out the
winter
and if we in the west can see out the
winter it's going to be a tough winter
for us in all sorts of ways and keep
ukrainians in the war
then next year i believe that the
pendulum will swing back towards ukraine
and ukraine will put russia under some
pressure now that's when it gets much
more dangerous than it is now and the
the russians will be looking then not to
be seen to lose and looking for a way
out that's when it gets politically very
very interesting but we've all got i
keep saying winter is coming we've all
got a tough winter to come and and just
under a minute left does boris johnson
departing number 10 make a difference or
because both candidates whoever will
replace him have a similar overall
policy towards ukraine it it should make
a difference yeah i think we've got a
national consensus on ukraine it's one
of the very few things that all the
parties agree on apart from jeremy
corbyn
and all the public agree on that we
support ukraine and we are we're not you
know we are appalled by what russia has
done we're the most um intransigent in a
way or the most resolute anti-russian
country in europe we always were and
we're proving it again now so it's one
of the sort of the sort of thing that
doesn't divide the parties in britain
and i don't think it will in the future
professor michael clark always a
pleasure thanks so much uh for answering
all those many questions excellent
questions from our viewers over the
course of uh that last hour six months
of course uh into the war amazing to
think that 181
uh days this war has been going on uh
still to come on on sky news uh tonight
uh lots more to come in fact we'll be
speaking to a uh senior uh russian
member uh of putin's advisory team at
least he's a senior
in the delegation
from russia to the un to get their take
on six months into the war we'll also be
live in liverpool as police say people
are coming forward with information on
the killing of olivia pratt corbell but
need more information still we'll be
there next on sky news tonight